[موسيقى]
حياكم الله قررت حركته طالبان حضرت تعليم
الجامعي للنسائي في افغانستان الى اجل غير
مسمى وابقى رساله واجهتها وزاره التعليم
العالي الى جميع الجامعات الحكوميه
والخاصه قرار ان اثار قلقا عميقا وتمديدا
بالاوساط الدوليه وضغوطا على طالبان
بالتراجع طالبا مررت قرارها بانها تنشغل
بالبث في المناهج التعليميه وزي الرسمي
للفتيات فيما الفتيات الافغانيات غير
مقتنعات بهذه التمريرات لان الطالبان على
سده الحكم منذ نحو 16 شهرا وكان يجب عليها
ان تتغلب على هذه المشاكل اين كانت وصدر
هذا المرسوم في وقت اغلقتها المدارس فوق
الصف السادس الابتدائي امام الفتيات
الافغانيات لنحو عام واربعه اشهر ما اثر
انتقادات داخليه لكنها لم تؤدي الى نتائج
ملموسه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستديو ونور الله
السلاب البحث السياسي الافغانيه وايضا
ينضم الينا من كابول الدكتور فضل من الله
ممتازه دبلوماسيه السابق لابدا اولا مع
ضيفي هنا في الاستديو كيف تقرا هذا القرار
هو قرار
ربما يعتبره البعض لاسباب دينيه يريد تريد
طالبان الحفاظ على المجتمع ومن ثم مراجعه
كل ما حدث خلال الفتره الماضيه بالنسبه
للتعليم النساء
اذا كانت مستقله وتتخذ قراراتها بنفسها
وتهتم بشان الافغاني فكان ينبغي لها ان
تفتح المدارس وتفتح المجالات امام المراه
الافغانيه امام الشعب الافغاني وان يح
للاعتراف الدولي على انفسهم اذا كانوا
فعلا يهتمون بالدين فالدين لا يمنع تعليم
المراه في اي مكان نحن عندنا اكثر من 57
دوله اسلاميه وعربيه وكلها تطبق الشريعه
وفيها الانظمه التراعي حكما الله سبحانه
وتعالى وفيها التعليم على اعلى ما يكون
والناس يهيئون شعوبهم
للمتطلبات السوق العالميه الكبيره وهمم
والاحتياجات العالميه اما ان ناتي لها
هؤلاء الدراويش الذين الان يحكمون
افغانستان ما عندهم مضمون ما عندهم ماده
ليشغلوا الشعب الافغاني فيها ياتوا يبداون
بشان المراه ويجب ان لا تذهب الى المدرسه
يجب ان لا تذهب الى الجامعه لا يجب ان لا
تعمل يا اخي انت عندك اكثر من مليون وظيفه
اخرى اساسيه للدوله يجب ان تقوم بها انت
جيت 20 سنه وكنت تقتل وتفجر وتلغم وتدمر
الوطن الان هذا الوقت كان تثبت انك فعلا
كنت تريد اعمار هذا الوطن بالتعليم بالقيم
الافغانيه لا يوجد هناك اي شيء
يمنع التعليم في هذا الوقت في افغانستان
اذهب الى ضيفي من كابول همم يعني سيد
الدكتور فضل من الله كيف ترى هذا امر
دنيوي يريدون اشغال الشعب كما يقول ضيفي
هنا في في الاستديو كيف ترى ذلك
هناك كانت التقاط في العالم انه
خلال شرين سنه قد تغير الامور او قد قد
تغير اعتقادات وافكار طالبان هذا كان خاتي
جدا امريكي
كان يفتخر بذلك وكان يعتقد انه طالبان ليس
طالبان القديم ولكن انا اقول بكل صراحه ان
طالبان حكم ثالثا لمده خمس سنوات في هذه
الاولى وبالتالي لن يتغير وهؤلاء همم بكل
صراحه قال وزير التعليم العالي قال نحن لا
نريد ان نتنازل عن ما اعتقد بسبب ارضاء
المجتمع الدولي او ضغوطات الدوليه هذا
الذي يقول وهو كذلك اسر وقال بكل الصراحه
نحن جينا همم وصلنا الى الحكم بغلبه
اللي بواسطه الدرقيه فلا يمكن ان نحن
نتنازل الا يتحققها اهداف الذين نعتقد في
نفس الوقت حمق قالوا هذا كلام بصراحه قال
انه نحن ما جئنا عن طريق الانتخابات وقال
هذا لاعيبه اخونا امير لحركه الطالبان قال
نحن يعني ما جيتوا عن طريقه الانتخابات او
عن طريق صوت الشعب ان ما تجيب لنا نحن
بقوه لماذا لماذا
الان لماذا بعد وصولهم الى سده الحكم
يراجعون ويغلقون المدارس عداء الصفه
الابتدائي والان الجامعات لماذا بعد ثلاثه
اشهر من اداء الامتحانات للقبول الجامعي
حتى الامر من المستغرب جدا لانها قبل شهر
تقريبا اختبار ماده التاريخ انحاء الثانوي
دخول الفتيات الى جامعه قرابه الثلاثين
الف من طالبات هم الذين اختبرنا وسجلنا
الى الجامعات للكليات التي كانت كنا
ترغبنا الدخول لكليات هذا غريب ولكن امر
الذي ممكن نحن نستغرب من هذا الامر لماذا
هذا هو لماذا الان اتخذوا هذا القرار هناك
يقال ربما يكون هناك انشقاق لان اختلال
انشقاق تباين بين جماعتين جماعه سياسيه
وجمال عسكريه يعني ترجح عمليه الانشقاق في
او خلاف داخل طالبان طيب هنا ضيفي في
الاستوديو نور الله سلاب اليوم حينما
نتحدث انه طالبان لم تعلن عن نفسها همم
بدوله مدنيه هي تريد الحفاظ على قيم
المجتمع وتريد على المراه
بالتالي بالتالي لباس المراه التعليم
بتراء بان هذه المناهج بحاجه الى اعاده
صياغه نحن هذا الذي كنا ننتظر منهم خلال
سنه وثلاثه اشهر ان ياتوا منهج جديد يا
اخي انت كانت عندك فرصه كافيه عندما
استلمت هذه الوزارات للتربيه وللتعليم
العالي ولكل الوزارات التي فيها المراه
وفيها فرصه لعمل المراه تعال
بمخطتك بدراستك بقانونك بدراستك بشيء انت
خلال سنه ونصف الى الان لم تكتب ولا صفحه
يعني هو يريد اشغال المجتمع بقضايا الدفاع
عن حقوق المراه ولا ماذا ليست له اي علاقه
بالدين ليست له اي علاقه بالعرف والعادات
والتقاليد الافغانيه الافغان الان يريدون
تعليم المراه هم يتحدثون عن اشياء قبل 60
سنه كانت هناك همم افكار ضد التعليم الان
الشعب كله يريد ان يخرج للمدارس
والاولادهم يتعلموا ويذهبوا الى العمل
هؤلاء انما لا يجدون مضمون ليشغل الشعب
الافغاني ان ياتوا بشيء خلال سنه ونصف ما
وجدوا اي شيء معارض للشريعه الاسلاميه في
افغانستان الشعب مسلم والدستور كان اسلامي
وما المحاكم كانت مستقله وتحكم بالكتاب
والسنه لم يجدوا شيء معارض للشريعه الان
يتفلسفون بهذه القصص تعالوا لنخلق قصه
للعالم ولنشغل العالم باشياء تافهه يا اخي
انت الان ما وصلت الى الحكم بالغلبه انت
وصلت للحكم بالدجل والشعوذه وبالتنسيق مع
الامريكان هم نقل السلطه اليك في الدوحه
جلسوا هناك سنه وثمانيه اشهر على ماذا
كنتم تتحدثون على اي الدستور كنتم
تتعاملوا لاي مصالح امريكيه كنتم توقعون
هناك
الضغط الدولي الان يجب ان يكون صريح ويجب
ان يكون مؤثر يعني اليه تنفيذيه يضغطوا
لها هؤلاء لان هؤلاء الان لا يرون اي
تاثير لاي ضغوطات دوليه المال القادم افضل
هناك
بشنط بالدولارات تاتي للدوله شهريا
يستلمون 250 مليون دولار من الغرب ومن
المؤسسات الدوليه الدكتور الدكتور فضل من
الله الادانات الدوليه والضغط الدولي هل
ممكن ان يغير موقف طالبان
هذا الذي لن يؤثر ابدا حناك تقدر تشوف
هناك انقسام همم دوله او نقول نفاق دولي
من ناحيه السين ولروسيا همم هؤلاء همم
يعتبرون هذه الاشياء شانا داخليا افغانيا
لا يهتمون بهذا الموضوع نهائيا انما الدول
الغربيه امام كاميراتهم الذين يتحدثون ان
الحقوق المراه حقوق همم انسان مثل هذا
الكلام مثل هذا ولكن اكثر ما هم في
لقاءاتهم السريه يركزون ما قاده التاليبان
هم على موضوع امور الشعله الامور الامنيه
فقط
لا تكون افغانستان
كما هم يسمونه ويقولون ذلك انما امام
كاميرات انما يتحدث دكتور
هذا الموضوع نعم
ممتازه الدبلوماسيه السابق من كابول شكرا
جزيلا لك الشكر موصول هنا لضيفي في
الاستوديو سيد نور الله البحث السياسي
الغني شكرا جزيلا لكما
اشكرك منصور لكم ما انتم المزيد من
الاخبار مع الزملاء في نشاراتنا المستمر
اترككم في امان الله